617 830 4750 is the number we will take
one more call name and town who's next
on the line with us 917 caller hello
hello hello yeah well it's me yeah yeah
do you hear me we can hear you okay yeah
so um like I don't really give my name
away a moment my pseudo name online is
to secular brownie I have i'm also
content creator like yourself also the
first and foremost I'd like to invite
you to my channel from time to come on
and talk and the second the second part
of that conversation is a few months ago
i've always been saying I've always been
telling my friends um in in response to
progressive identity politics from news
outlets like BuzzFeed Huffington Post
there's going to be white identity
politics white supremacy white
nationalism will be there the response
oh yeah we want our own I dated
politician now we see with the alright
reactionary dirty politics yeah and in
Hillary Clinton's campaign you know she
focused on at any politics where he's
Donald Trump focused on working class
white so my question was what we're
leading on to is right now we're seeing
in the in the left-wing this debate
about identity politics where progress
on four veces want to hold on to it I
mean it's they use their ID politics if
you legitimised intellectually and while
others are like no let's focus on
humanist politics and things of that
sort so the two questions are first you
know will you come on my channel to talk
sometime the second part is how do you
and I as fellow progressives who want
progressive values to be all about
empowering everybody you know including
minorities address this um address this
need for any politics remarkable
progresses we'll listen hopefully the
2016 election results will wake up some
progressive to the reality that what
what some call identity liberalism is
aside from the sort of ethical moral
merits of it it doesn't work to win
elections in many cases because
ultimately you need to be able to appeal
to something broader even those in the
majority right i mean most white people
I know are concerned about minority
rights are concerned about the treatment
of and
discrimination against all of the
different groups that you alluded to
whether it's sexual identity orientation
race gender nationality whatever the
case may be but and over uh when you're
overly focused on that in a national
election that is just from a
mathematical standpoint not going to
resonate with necessarily enough people
to win you the election that's what we
saw you're absolutely right that the all
right you know there's this incredible
double standard of the all right which
is they slam the left for identity
politics but they have a totally
identity politics based movement based
on this idea of white man is being
oppressed and in many cases the the ties
with white nationalism etcetera I mean
it's totally bogus but you're right that
because it exists as a sort of
counterpoint to identity liberalism it
has been perceived as much more
legitimate or valid than it is so I
don't know the answer I know what I'm
going to do and I'm going to focus on
issues that are of concern to everybody
which by extension will impact all of
those minority groups and I don't know
what else can really be done in the
short term also the first part question
is we call my channel some time to have
a talk I don't know about that I have no
idea what your channel is but I'm glad
to consider it if you email in through
our website contact form so that's not a
question I can answer right now but I
will certainly consider it i would
suggest sending in an email through our
website david pakman.com all right that
is going to do it for our calls today
the indy gogo fundraiser is on david
pakman.com slash donate is the place to
check it out thanks to all of our
callers and we will take more calls next
week